if we just do behavior cloning using
this data you know won't cut it like we
don't have enough data
hello there today we're going to look at
this right here this is an agent in
minecraft that's trying to build a
waterfall so the goal is to go up a
mountain
find a good spot
put down some water turn around and then
take a beautiful picture of the
waterfall that is one of the four tasks
of the mine rl basalt competition this
is what we're going to talk about today
and not only are we going to talk about
the challenge the competition
as you can see make waterfall is one of
the four subtasks we're actually going
to talk to the winning team to the
kairos team in just a second this is
just the intro i want to tell you a
little bit about what's going on so that
later in the interview with the authors
uh you can follow if you don't know what
minecraft is or sort of the basics of
these competitions if you do feel free
to skip ahead this is just gonna take
five to ten minutes right here
so i'm going to just show you another
one to give you a little bit of the
impression of what these agents can do i
i haven't actually looked at many of
them i don't know what's going to happen
right here whether that's successful or
not these are the actual videos that the
judges uh saw
that
were part of these competitions so the
competition is human judged there's no
reward function it's literally you just
give 10 videos to a human and they're
supposed to rate how good these things
are how human-like they are and so on ah
it missed the waterfall a little bit
right there let's see whether it can
turn around
yeah it can uh not spot on as you can
imagine
and not spot on in any of the ten things
but good enough to win this competition
so how did this team go about this if
you don't know what minecraft is
minecraft is this game that's it looks
like you know it's it looks like uh it's
from 1990 or so everything is made of
blocks but it is a really cool game it's
a completely open world game you can do
anything and everything you can craft
items all of these blocks you can
destroy and build up somewhere else uh
you can collect items and craft new
better items from it for example you can
craft a pickaxe with which you can mine
things mine stone from that you can
build like an oven a smelter and smelt
iron ore from that you can build iron
tools and so on this world is
completely procedurally generated so
there's there's no
the level is never the same and that's
one of the things that makes these
challenges so hard and the other thing
is just the sheer amount of freedom that
you have right here so the agent now has
spent quite a bit of time looking for a
good place to build the waterfall it
looks like it got stuck right here that
must that that's kind of one of the
failure cases i imagine or it's gonna
get out
it's gonna get out wha what a what a
clint glitch glitch play there
it looks like here it's a good spot for
waterfall yes put it down
walk away from it turn around
snap picture
with the sheep in it beautiful
so
this has actually led to
a paper as well by the winning team
called combining learning from human
feedback and knowledge engineering to
solve hierarchical tasks in minecraft
along with open source code that you can
check out so you can
retrain their agent you can look at
their code and you can improve it it's
mit licensed therefore you know all good
to go for you
so what did this team do
that gave them the winning submission
the challenge in itself is you're given
the tasks in just a short string so
there's not a reward function or
anything like this the
short string literally is for example
the find cave it's the agent should
search for a cave and terminate the
episode when it is inside one that is
the entire description of the task as i
said no reward functions
you do get 40 to 80 i believe play
throughs 40 to 80 human demonstrations
for each task
not all of them completing the task
though
and a bit of a code base and that's it
this team came up with the following
solution they built at the core they
built what they call a state machine but
i want to start somewhere else i want to
start from how they used the human
demonstrations so they had human
demonstrations of humans solving this
task and then they trained a navigation
policy this is trained via behavior
cloning so you try to
make an agent that just kind of clones
the
human movements
they did cut out all of the
sort of interacting with the environment
things from the human demonstrations
such that it was just only navigation
going from point a to point b this is a
policy that they can activate at any
time so as you can see right here this
gives rise to these to one of what they
call
learned or engineered sub tasks so you
they have a stack of these subtasks one
of them is this navigation subtask that
is obviously learned they have other
ones that are just hard coded for
example when it's time to actually place
the waterfall at that point when you
think you're at a good point to build a
waterfall this movement of stacking up
the blocks and then putting the
waterfall on top that is a hard-coded
policy so these subtasks are hard-coded
partially and partially learned and
they're controlled by this state machine
um on top of that state machine which
we're gonna get to in a minute um the
state machine itself is controlled by
this state classifier so the state
classifier
is
a thing that they came up with
they take
pictures from the game frames from the
game and they collect additional human
labeled data where for each picture they
let the humans label for example is this
inside a cave which you can see right
here that's inside a cave if you play
minecraft you you'd know uh is there
danger ahead which means kind of a large
body of water that you should avoid or
something like this
do you have animals which is relevant
for some of the tasks so they build up
this state classifier which is also
learned and that state classifier is now
going to control this state machine i'm
not sure if they actually have it
somewhere for one of the tasks in the
paper they do have it in the
accompanying presentation
the state machine controls
what the age or which
sub policy is active at any given point
let's see
it's not here
well i can maybe maybe i can i can draw
it a little bit you're going to see in
the presentation so you start and then
you for example if it's the make
waterfall task you go you get to a point
where you want to ask is there a good
spot to place the waterfall is a good
spot in sort of the view of the agent if
no
then you go to the explore sub-policy
and if yes
then you go to the
go there
the go there sub policy
is activated
these are these sub-policies that
we saw or either learned or hard-coded
for example the explore one you can
imagine maybe it's just sort of walking
around until the state class classifier
tells you that there is actually a good
spot so what makes the decision between
no and yes that is exactly this state
classifier this trained state classifier
at some point it will tell you ah now
you found a good spot and then you can
switch policy so from there
if after the go there you get to another
decision point and the decision point uh
might be
like are you in front of a of a big wall
if yes use the jump policy if no
use the walk policy or something like
this so
as you can see the state machine itself
is hard coded so the humans came up with
what do we need to do to complete the
tasks but the individual steps they can
be either learned or
hard-coded policies and that's how they
go through fulfilling these tasks they
use the state classifier to always tell
them what specific sub-task here should
be activated at any given point
controlled by the state machine
and you know with that they they finish
the task one additional thing that they
sometimes need is this estimated
odometry this is where they
just look at the actions they've
performed so far and they built this
overhead map of the agent as you as the
agent walks through the environment uh
they're able to sort of remember things
for example this here is has animals so
they remember they're gonna remember
locations of animals of bodies of water
and so on and that allows them later if
on in the later stages if they need to
go back to something
they can efficiently find it again for
example in the waterfall subtask they
have to go away from the waterfall turn
around to put the waterfall inside of
their field of view and then take a
picture or finish the episode
that could be controlled by this
overhead map that they build up it's
pretty interesting all the while they
only have access to the image of the
simulator they do not have access to
like the f3 menu or anything like this
all they have is the image they do have
some information on their inventory and
their current item but not much more
than that
all right that was it from me if you're
interested read this paper it's a pretty
good write-up and also it has a lot of
evaluation they did a lot of human
evaluation as well uh computing these
true skill ranking scores and so on to
compare their system and do various
ablations it's really interesting but
now i want to give over to the interview
part of this let me know how you like
these more interviewee style of ways of
presenting papers this one is obviously
very
very applied paper very visual paper but
yeah let me know what you think and now
enjoy
hi everyone uh welcome welcome this is
this is a really really awesome
opportunity right here i'm joined by the
winning team of the mayan rl basalt
challenge 2021
uh by david watkins nick waytowicz and
vinicius gerks who managed to somehow
lock their way into winning this
competition no i'm kidding i'm kidding
um this
it it's really awesome i've seen the
videos
of your agent and congratulations first
of all on winning and uh welcome uh to
the channel
thanks for having us
yeah thank you very much for having us
we are excited to talk about the work
so
if you could describe in your words the
the challenge itself um the challenge is
about
just sort of a bunch of tasks and then
humans rate
these tasks how have you
what make what made you decide to take
part in this challenge even how did you
find it did you just stumble across each
other how did you form your team like
what what was your interest in this
um well i can say that so we all work
together uh so that's it it wasn't like
uh we kind of found each other we've had
prior experience
working together at the army research
lab
and
you know i think vinicius was actually
the one that stumbled upon this
challenge and what we liked about this
challenge was that it's you know it's
it's different from most other machine
learning challenges out there different
from other ai competitions and the fact
that you know you don't have an
objective function to optimize over
right so it immediately makes it harder
you know the challenge again like is in
minecraft with these very free-form you
know almost lifelike tasks where really
you just have a description a human
readable description of what that task
is there's no reward function no
objective function
so automatically means you can't just
apply a standard reinforcement learning
techniques um and you have to you know
employ some sort of you know clever
measures and potentially learning from
humans which is really what the the core
of the challenge is about learning from
humans um and that's actually you know
each of us have machine learning
backgrounds and the research that we do
is is kind of human guided uh machine
learning so this challenge was almost
like perfect for us like oh this is this
is a great challenge we knew it was
going to be hard um but yeah
that was kind of the the calling for us
and just so um
for i i will have introduced this but
the challenge was there were four tasks
and every task was just given if i
understand correctly like a very short
description of what to do so for example
find cave is the agent should search for
a cave and terminate the episode when it
is inside one right that is that is all
and all you have as an input if i
understand this correctly is the screen
right no nothing more well you do have
the screen and you do have your
inventory and
the item that you have currently
equipped
uh yeah and the screen 64 by 64 rgb
that that is a horrible resolution
but you you do not you do not have
because in minecraft for people who play
it there's f3 right uh you can press it
you see your coordinates you see sort of
your biome and so on um not you have
none of that you have to sort of do
everything from from the screen alone
and you're given
40 to 80 human demonstrations if i know
this correctly but not all of them
successful right
is that that was a surprise for us as
well when we were
using those demonstrations in our asian
and we realized like look at this guy he
just walked around and through the
snowball to end the episode how is that
even useful like it was a surprise for
us as well
and and sometimes you get some items so
one of the challenges for example is um
to
it's called create village animal pen
where it is uh after spawning in a
village build an animal pen next to one
of the houses in a village animal pens
must contain two of a single kind of
animal you're only allowed to pen
chickens cows pigs or sheep don't harm
the village and you're in this case
you'd be given also some sort of a fence
and fence gates in order to build uh the
pen so it's not like you would have to
go collect resources but
the task is still quite challenging
exactly yeah you don't have to collect
any resource or build anything you were
given everything on your inventory but
like completing all those tasks was
already a huge challenge so
yeah and especially given that you again
to remind people uh the reward here is
not some function you can compute the
reward is at the end it's given to human
raters the human reads the description
and then the human decides how well did
your agent perform it and most striking
i find this in in a third task that is
build waterfall where the goal is that
you have to i can maybe read the
description after spawning in a
mountainous area the agent should build
a beautiful waterfall that's part of the
description a beautiful waterfall and
then reposition itself to take a scenic
picture of the same waterfall
the picture of the waterfall can be
taken by orienting the camera and then
throwing a snowball when facing the
waterfall at a good angle so there is
even an essence of sort of a
subjectivity judgment beauty and so on
in it so that that just you know that is
the challenging part i think here what
was your first
you saw this you thought i want to do
this challenge we want to do this
challenge what was your first try
like what did you what was the first
thing you threw at the problem well i i
can speak a little bit about it like
at least me myself like when i read like
the challenge i had no idea how to
approach it
because i was thinking okay we have a
few demonstrations but like from you
know my experience research and
everything i thought if we just do
behavior cloning using this data you
know won't cut it like we don't have
enough data and then we like it took us
like a month to choose solidify like an
approach we thought about behavior
cloning we talked about uh gayo
uh we thought about like okay let's hard
code this whole thing
uh we definitely thought about different
approaches and then i guess in the end
it was a mix of everything
and that's what we make clear so there
is a paper
about you wrote a paper about your
approach as well and the the papers uh
title is combining learning from human
feedback and knowledge engineering to
solve hierarchical tasks in minecraft
sort of pointing out that the best
approach uh will be one where learned
elements are mixed with uh hand
engineered elements
how did you so my question is sort of
how did you
come about this was this an iterative
process or did you
you said you scrambled with a bunch of
things at the beginning did you add and
add and that what was your what was your
process uh what was the first thing that
maybe you realized ah this works now a
little right and and then how did you
build up your your end solution
well so i can uh add a little bit to
that so
um
you know
we were motivated like the nice thing
about the competitions were motivated to
try to do well and
and so we we knew
from the beginning that we didn't want
we wanted to take a different approach
probably a lot of people would you know
just try to apply and and machine
learning
you know throw a lot of compute at it
and you know we kind of realized that
really if we want a solution that is a
little less just academic and more that
works for this particular application
we're going to need to
really use everything right
including you know
try to inject our own
domain bias about the problem
into the framework into the solution so
that really led us to these you know
okay well we could have a hierarchy of
uh different modules some of those are
hand engineered some of those are
learned you know the things that we
can't engineer um and then
we can have like you know a state
machine where we we we know the agent
should be doing this so you know let's
let's not have the
the
you know ro or machine learning
component learn the things that we
already know how to do from scratch
right and just make this job harder
right let's add that information to the
agent and let's you know
save the learning for the things that we
can't easily do right and then have them
work together
yeah i i think you make this clear and
i'm just going to share a screen uh for
a bit right here
you make this clear in sort of this
diagram which is an overview over your
system and
at the core here is this this state
machine you want to maybe talk a little
bit about why a state machine might make
sense right here
for example this here is the state
machine for
for the waterfall task
okay i can talk a little bit about it
so
if you saw like those tasks so for
example let's let's talk about the build
waterfall task since we have the diagram
open there's
there's really like a hierarchy of
of subtasks that need needs to be
complete in order you know choo choo you
know to finish this whole task for for
example for the make waterfall right you
first you need to find a good spot to
build your waterfall right and that that
means you need to climb up somewhere you
need to be like at the edge of a cliff
right and then you have to actually
build the waterfall you know you got to
equip your water bucket and you know
point it down
through the water bucket right and then
hopefully this waterfall will be
beautiful right assuming you got like a
good spot then you have to go really far
away from this waterfall and then
position your camera just right to get
like the best you know the best view of
this waterfall and throw is no ball to
finish it right so there's this whole
hierarchy of tasks it needs to be
completed like one step at a time and
there's like this logical order so the
state machine was our approach to make
sure that the agent would actually
follow this order you know without
coming back and forth like if you do
like for example some just an enchant
machine learning approach the agent
might you know let's say go find a spot
and then we'll go back take a picture
you know
come back again try to build uh equip
the water bucket to build the waterfall
so the state machine was our solution to
to make sure the agent would follow
canada's logic for each task
and
i think you profit from the fact that
all of these tasks can be sort of
described quite well in this state
machine fashion as i think a lot of you
know if if you play minecraft as a human
that's sort of the same thing you do
right you if you want to beat the ender
dragon you okay first i need to do this
then this then this and it's quite the
same thing with a few decision nodes in
between and these decision nodes here in
the in the green those are now decided
by uh classifier if understand this
correctly so you build this this little
interface here where humans
could rate you were allowed in the
competition to collect a little bit like
a limited amount of different human
feedback
and you chose among other things you
chose to have humans label different
images from the game with
such uh
with um
with such
maybe you can describe it a little bit
what were you interested in and why did
you choose to put the additional human
labeling into this task and not any
other task what like
why did you prefer this
something important to keep in mind is
that you're allowed to include 30
megabytes of additional data in this
competition
and the minecraft simulator is such that
if you were to record a bunch of actions
or
steps that the player took and try to
replay them
it's not currently designed to handle
rng the same way every time so
if i go
break a block that block is going to fly
differently depending on the state the
internal state of the uh random number
generator and we have no control over
that
so so you can't seed it necessarily we
can't exceeding it just doesn't work so
okay
we we couldn't just collect more
demonstration data other than videos and
that would eat into 30 megabytes very
quickly as i'm sure you could imagine
so dividing up each of the tasks into a
bunch of shared states
made the most sense to us
it's something we've used in previous
research to handle
uh navigation tasks before
and it works reliably and and i think
there's a lot of research in making
state classifiers work really well
so it was more just us as a team
you know while we're watching tv
labeling a bunch of minecraft screens
the most difficult part of course though
is it's 64 by 64.
and there are many situations where
maybe you want to recognize that there's
an animal in the frame and at the
chicken and it's the small white blob
but it could be confused with a flower
and you're kind of fighting yourself to
make sure that
this actually works and so there were
some different strategies we were
looking to employ to make sure that um
the state was classified correctly
but
it worked pretty well
cool and
i think people can see here maybe at
this graphic but you have such things
like for example good waterfall view
which makes sense right this is a
subjective thing of the reward function
so it makes total sense to include that
in the human uh in the human
annotated data and not and not code a
heuristic but you also have things like
a danger ahead uh which you then
use so
i think
um
once
once you know which node you're in right
in in this in this state machine uh very
often
the blue blocks right here which are the
actions the blue blocks involve going
somewhere right for example if has
mountain then you know if if you don't
have a mountain find a mountain if you
do have a mountain go to the mountain
and that part means that your minecraft
agent has to go from you know point a to
point b and that's where you build a
specialized uh navigation
um navigation
subroutine and you said right now you've
already done this in the past can you
tell maybe a little bit in general what
does it take to make agents navigate
around
so um
can i
just mention one more thing about the
state classifier
sure
it's not from all right so
with the state class for like david and
vinicius were saying right it's really
the core of the state machine right uh
so we knew we wanted you know it's the
it's the thing that makes the drives our
entire solution so it has to be you know
more or less somewhat accurate and we
needed a lot of data and so we actually
collected around i think 88 000 labels
um which sounds like a lot
but
and of course you know that type of
manual annotating no one really wants to
do
you know as machine learning scientists
we rather spend that time trying to you
know code up a solution to do that
instead of doing it ourselves but what
we did we try to make it as easy as
possible by
um
you know we're not hci experts but you
know we tried to come up with a
kind of intuitive labeling interface to
make it as quick as possible to kind of
um
you know like
one demonstration that's three minutes
long at a you know
fps of 20 frames per second
you know that's a lot of images and we
try to take advantage of the fact that
the images are you know somewhat
correlated through time right so the way
we designed our labeling interface is
kind of just a step through
um each image to the trajectory
and if you you uh hold down a button
let's say uh one of the buttons is you
know there's there's nothing ahead it's
just open fields so you can just hold
down that button and it's going to
traverse you know through the
demonstration until something else comes
up and then you can just move a
different button so very quickly you
know you can you know label 5000 images
in one trajectory in like less than a
minute because you're just holding down
these buttons instead of like you know
showing an individual image and then
selecting the label and then the next
image and selecting label i think that
really allowed us to get it it
sacrifices a little bit of accuracy
maybe when you're transitioning you
might miss uh you know get a few
misclassifications but you're able to
get a lot more
more labeled images
i i think this is a recurring theme sort
of in
real world tasks the efficiency of of
data labeling uh when you include humans
uh i've just recently watched sort of uh
elon elon musk's appearance on lex
friedman and before that i've i've
commented on karpati's talk about the
autopilot there it's a thing that you
see again and again that
the easier you make it for humans to
annotate data the the more benefit you
have later like it's almost it's almost
uh an unfair like multiplier that you
have on your system i think it's
neglected currently by academia so it's
pretty cool that you you thought about
this as well
yeah i think i think it is neglected
because it is not easy and takes a lot
of time and like manual labor nobody
wants to do manual labor but
definitely having like a high quality
label data labeled by humans makes
totally the difference
so
and now we'll let's let's go to the to
the navigation uh sub routine how do you
how do you navigate wait that is
here
so you have a navigation policy which
essentially says the agent needs to go
from a
to b
and
what does it take to build that like
it's it seems very complicated in a ter
in a game so complicated as minecraft so
well so okay the the behavioral cloning
part all right so that part is you know
unfortunately just very simple it's not
any secret sauce or anything complicated
um you know we again just prefacing by
this you know was a competition and we
had a deadline we had so much more that
we wanted to do with this particular
part right for to solve the navigation
part we wanted to do something you know
way more than just standard behavioral
cloning you know things like um
generative adversarial imitation
learning
um you know trying to
have better architectures in the end we
didn't have enough time we we were
scrambling and for this uh component we
just did behavioral cloning but the way
that we did that is you know as you can
see in this model it's like okay the the
uh agent only has the image as input and
its output um you know are more or less
just the direction key so it can go
forward it can turn left it can turn
right it can strafe left strafe right
and then it can move its camera
um and and really the way that we did
that is we just we had all these
demonstrations for each of these tasks
we kind of the only kind of trick that
we applied was that okay we realized
that this is just a navigation component
so we only want to learn to imitate the
damage part of the demonstrations that
we're navigating right so let's just
chop off that demonstration just to that
navigation part and then feed that into
our uh
navigation policy and so that's that's
basically what we did was you know any
any time where the agent was building
um like building the pen or the village
or the waterfall we we cut those
segments out and we the remaining
segments are where the agent is just
trying to go from what uh one point to
the next uh we kept those in and use
that as our training data for the
behavioral cloning module
and in this in in this model here it
says image input do you also give the
model access to let's say the uh the
results of your state classifier and
maybe the current state machine uh state
or something like this so the agent
knows where to go or do you rely on
behavior cloning for the entirety of
navigation
yeah that's a really good point so again
it's
our this particular navigation policy is
just terribly simple
it's really just the the image input
um
it's
being driven by the state classifier in
the sense that it
allow you know the state classifier
decides when to start and stop the
navigation policy but we're not feeding
in any information directly from the
state classifier or other um
other more interesting information that
that certainly would help if we had more
time we could
probably do that it would make sense to
do that but uh right now the state
classifier just decides when to to start
that navigation policy and when to
terminate the navigator
i think okay sorry go ahead no i just
just went and i had a little bit on top
of that like the main reason we didn't
add anything else on this is because we
didn't have
so like the so this navigation subtask
policy was trained from the
demonstrations provided by the
competition so that data didn't have any
like state machine so the state machine
was everything on our side uh so we
really only had access uh
to the actions that the agent took right
and the camera data
and
and again like i think the using that
demonstration data provided by by the
competition to train only the navigation
subtests made sense because
uh let's say think about it let's say we
want to
do end-to-end behavior cloning right and
then you were doing the fine cave task
and the find the cave task at some point
the human will throw a snowball when the
agent is inside the cave right and
that's only one data simple and the
whole episode has about two to three
thousand so you haven't one same sample
to throw in the snowball
on over like you know three thousand
samples but to find the the cave it took
a lot of steps and this is all really
useful for navigation so uh we did this
like next had this uh pre-process to
remove all those actions leave only the
navigation part and use that to train
this navigation subtask
and i think that was pretty helpful to
uh in our approach
so
is it it's fair to say that for example
you're here and um you your your house
mountain classifier says yes then the
state machine would simply activate the
navigation
does it but it doesn't it doesn't
necessarily tell it where to go you just
rely on the fact that your demonstration
in your demonstration uh people
have generally gone towards the mountain
and therefore the navigation policy
would have learned that implicitly
exactly let me i guess let me explain
this diagram a little bit so what you
said is correct so the green diamonds
are decision notes right and that's
that's based on the output of the the
state classifier right so like has
mountings you know if it's over let's
say 90 confidence we'll take that as a
yes right and then we go to those
blue
rectangles
and each blue rectangle is a subtask
and those subtasks can be either learned
or coded or like hard coded so for
example go to go or find go
actually find go was uh learned from the
human demonstration so
uh we would not say like something like
oh go to this coordinate like we didn't
have right we would just use the the
human
the policy that was trained from human
demonstrations to navigate let's say
going up the mountain right and then
let's say
on that uh part of the diagram where you
have the dashed line you know there's a
green
diamond there written at the top so
let's say if the state classifier detect
that we were on top of the the mounting
right then we would switch to this place
waterfall step task
and this place waterfall subtask was
hard coded so that was not learned from
the human demonstrations
and what the subtest does is basically
point your camera down keep the water
bucket and throw it you know that's kind
of placing the waterfall so those blues
are are a mix of learned subtasks and
hard coded
yeah what
my question is a little bit you have for
example this danger ahead state right
but you don't feed any state to the
navigation policy where is the danger
ahead used is it inside the state
classifier somewhere like you say if
there's danger ahead then we don't even
want to activate navigation exactly so
that's something that it it's like a
safe critical subtask that takes
priority over everything so it doesn't
matter if you're looking at the mounting
whatever you need to do if there's
danger at hand just avoid it right so
it's like a sort of a safe override
that's always on no matter which subtask
we're doing if you're following the
human or not
because you know just avoid danger
because our first iterations of asian
and even the the final one still does
some time
when you fall on one of those lakes
you just can't escape it's just too hard
like
sometimes you're like two blocks uh tall
then it's hard to like teach the agent
to break the blocks and jump like do all
those things that us humans do pretty
well for the asian this is pretty hard
so our asian got stuck a bunch of times
then we had to to add like some uh
safety subtasks to help a little bit uh
the asian to escape those things
and at some point you also you also they
uh built in this this odometry
estimation um
because you only had the image and you
thought it would be
maybe you can explain this what led you
because it's not a straightforward thing
to include right if i think about how
would i solve this task uh what is
the odometry estimation what is it for
and why did you include it
i can talk about it uh so like you
mentioned in the beginning of the video
uh we could not like in minecraft we do
know where the agent is like when you're
playing the game right you can press
like f3 you can see everything right but
in the competition we were not allowed
to use that
right so
uh we had some ideas okay let's use the
simulator but we were not allowed to do
that but we're thinking like what do we
know about this problem right so we do
have access to the actions that the
asian took right and we do have access
to the image
not only that we know a little bit of
minecraft so
we know that the simulator runs at 20
frames per second
so each frame is 1 over 20 0.05 seconds
so we know this this this time interval
between each frame right
uh and from minecraft we know that for
example uh the walking distance is
actually i think
4.4.32 meters per second so we had this
information from the wiki
so let's say if the the agent
send the command to move forward right
and not considering inertia or anything
right we could assume that in one frame
the agent walked 4.32 times 0.05 right
so like this velocity times this dt this
time interval so we know uh how much the
agent
walked from the x direction right and
then
we had the actions we had excellent
access to the actions
uh for the camera control
so we could kind of estimate the heading
so just based on the actions that the
asian took
uh
and knowledge of the the simulator right
we're able to sort of estimate velocity
x
y and heading and then you integrate
that over time because you know your
time interval so you can come up with
estimates of x y
and heading for the agent and that's
what you see on this uh
kind of this black
diagram on the right which i can explain
everything in more details too
um you so but i mean you you built this
sort of
map almost like this is an overhead map
of the agent in its environment
annotated with
first of all what you've done so far
right your position that's uh that's
been going on maybe if if this here
loads this here
is different trajectories but you also
annotate this map with various things
that you find like whenever your state
classifier says something
where is this information used uh i
guess it's you said it's not in the
navigation because that
it doesn't get any additional features
where
is the information that you estimate
from from this this overhead map where
is it used the the best example for this
is to make waterfall task
so when the agent places a waterfall um
you know something we're thinking is
maybe we'll try the behavioral cloning
but often
you know the behavioral cloning doesn't
really stay still very often
because they really learned
well the navigation sub policy so
instead we we sort of use that heading
estimation
to move the agent away a fixed amount
and then rotate around to look at it
so there are just certain tasks that
it's really important that
whatever the final view is aligned with
some
landmark in the environment that we
don't have a
ground truth information for
yeah so it's really the the odometry is
mainly used in
various places in the state class where
iron started the state machine in in
some of the subtasks like dave was
saying another example is the animal pen
right because that the challenging part
of that task is you really have to build
you first got to find an open location
then build the pen
and then you have to leave that pin and
go find animals somewhere right they
could be anywhere and then lure them
back to the pen so you have to remember
where you built built that pin
um and so
that that's you know the odometry comes
into play for that place so we were
using the state classifier to kind of
classify okay here's an open location
now we switch to pin building mode okay
the pin is built let's go find some
animals
we remember the location of that pen
you know based on our estimated odometry
and then once we find some animals then
we
try to go back to that location and just
to say that the try to go back will be a
hard-coded policy that takes as an input
the remembered location of the pen and
your guess of where you are in relation
to that pen
exactly yeah so yeah at that stage you
have a x y coordinate of the pen and you
have an x y
and heading
estimates of your position right so you
can basically compute the angle between
like where you're looking and where the
pen is you can compute this angle right
and the policy was literally kind of
close this angle and then keep moving to
kind of reduce this distance over time
and go back to that location so the
simple policy there there are a few
limitations though on the odometry side
which i just want to comment just to
don't say this was like a god to your
approach for that so for example since
we only use uh the actions right
if you think about it
the odometry is just seeing the actions
right and then
okay the agent is moving forward so
we're seeing this moving forward action
right so we're integrating that over
time increasing the distance and
everything right but what if the agent
gets stuck like behind the rock behind
the tree and it is still moving forward
like in minecraft you can still kind of
walk forward sort of sliding right but
you're still stuck in place but the
odometry does not know that like we had
some some ideas to integrate like uh
different in the pixels right using this
camera data to know when when the agent
is stuck so we ignore that but we didn't
have time to do that at the end but this
approach uh our current approach still
works for a short short distance right
so of course the longer you walk you
know
like the the drift will be just higher
on this estimation but for short
distances actually actually works pretty
well
and i guess
sorry
i i was going to say that a slam
approach in a 64 by 64 image that's only
rgb is incredibly challenging and
probably not the right approach for this
particular challenge
and it's it might also be
be fair to say that you said you you had
a lot of ideas i guess uh if you were to
go further you'd probably let's say pro
try to come up with a navigation policy
that's both learned but also
controllable in some way try to come up
with an odometry estimation that takes
into account the picture which could
recognize when you're stuck and so on i
think there's there's a lot of stuff to
improve but i'm very impressed by sort
of your
your pragmatism of okay this works well
enough let's go on
uh was there
was there moments when
i guess there's moments in every project
when when you're
or what was the moment when you most
thought ah this is not gonna work let's
give up like did you have a moment like
this and and what did you do
you guys want to comment on that
well
there's there were i guess a lot of
those moments
we
uh if you go back to the main overall
diagram we definitely like had you know
went back and forth on on
on you know what should the solution be
you know
we were still toying around at some
points with with you know a more
you know end-to-end approach in some
places
and whether we should put our eggs in
that basket or whether we should do this
uh current approach ultimately you know
this is the the one that we landed on
and
we we designed this the nice thing about
this approach is it's it's hierarchical
but it's very modular right and the idea
is that each of these subtasks you know
their individual model modules that we
can improve upon or replace and uh
and so like you know if we had more time
the the some of the things that we would
do is start to try to replace some of
these hand engineered subtasks with more
learning based subtasks and or you know
replace the navigation module with a
more advanced learning module that uses
more information
one of the things we spent a lot of time
on that never made into or at least
was was kind of using uh generative
adversarial limitation learning as our
core
algorithm for learning the navigation
module
um
and you know with gale
it's you it's basically using again and
as we found out
like everybody knows pians are
notoriously difficult to stabilize
including gans for minecraft and
it didn't ultimately didn't end up
making it so we had to to revert back so
that was one of our certain areas we're
like oh
this is
this is definitely not going to work you
know we spent a ton of time doing that
and we had to kind of you know
replace with our with our backup which
is just you know standard behavior
cloning
so go ahead also um the
at one point we my brothers are very
good at minecraft and you know the
minecraft speed running community is a
it's a pretty big thing so at one point
we were considering why don't we just
get somebody to play minecraft really
well
but that stupid minecraft simulator
limitation and also
you know it's
it's one thing to get a bunch of people
to play the game better than maybe the
demonstrators were playing but that also
means that
you know
that data won't necessarily be very rich
because they can't play the game well
and label the data at the same time
and i think it comes back to this
problem of labeling data really
conveniently is
difficult especially when you're
driving the agent
simultaneously so it
it becomes a very difficult
challenge to use human data uh when the
the amount of data you can actually
collect is small
and this being minecraft i think i like
i'm fascinated by this because
i wonder how much world knowledge is in
inside a human when they play minecraft
and how much is sort of learned because
the world is different like literally
different every time and uh
i can learn minecraft by just watching
someone do it a few times right i can
perfectly not perfectly but i can well
generalized to other worlds is that
because i've watched someone i've done
it a bunch of times or is that because i
know from my life what sand is and what
water is and how it behaves and
i think that i don't
i don't know
yeah i think uh i guess the main
advantage of
like
you know humans is that you know we've
lived you know 20 30 17 years already
right on the reward and then minecraft
tries to mimic that so we humans have a
huge kind of baggage that we can use but
we have to always remember like those
asians they start from scratch they
literally start from nothing right we
had to collect they that should teach
what danger was for those asians like
like had to teach oh don't jump in the
water you know don't don't drown there
you know things like that
uh so that's
very challenging as well
and i have i have your um
so uh four
videos that you uploaded
and they have side by side the agent
view the classifier but also the
odometry estimation um
do you want to maybe so this is for
example do you have one that is your
favorite of these four uh probably the
waterfall i think will look pretty nice
so this is
build house was pretty challenging
this is uh 30 seconds i'm gonna i'm
gonna slow it down to like a point two
five right here um
do you maybe oh sorry yeah okay oh yeah
i can like
comment a little bit on what's happening
right here so which state is it in
what's happening yeah so so this is a
video of the agent uh solving the the
make waterfall task right and then you
mainly see in the screen in the screen
two panels so on the left side that's
the rgb
so this is like a camera view of the
agent right and on the right side this
black panel is the estimated odometry so
if we start there on top left you see
like action and then a huge tensor right
so that's the i think 12 or 13 actions
that the agent was performing so they're
mostly binaries so like move forward or
not move back or not you know things
like that uh and below that you see the
raw output of the state classifier so we
had uh 12 classes or i guess 13 with
you know the known class and you see
like the confidence of the classifier uh
you know for classifying the state like
this camera this camera image so you see
like right now you know facing wall is
pretty much almost 100 percent i think
it is from all the stone that the agent
is seeing so it thinks it is a wall
right
and on the right side the odometry so we
can start there on the on the top part
there
you see a x
a y and a heading so x y
so that's the estimated position of the
agent so that's not the ground truth so
again we didn't have the ground root
same with the heading so that's
estimated and that camera angle there is
like a vertical angle right
and then on the right side you have like
some time so we kind of just have a try
keep track of time and then you have a
legend so the legend there is for all
the the colors you see in the odometry
so the red one the red dot is the asian
so right now it is down at the bottom of
the screen
uh whenever uh the way the agent uh
walks around it leaves like this trace
so that's the white dashed line that you
see
uh in the screen
and then like right now you see for
example it just
saw that cyan i think
blob at the bottom there that's when the
state classifier detect that we're on
the top of the waterfall so you see that
that's the last thing on the legend
there
[Music]
so basically yeah the agent walks around
and some of the relevant states that we
classify we sort of drop a pin in the
map kind of just to keep track of it
so
in the video the first like 25 seconds
or so
what you know this is the you know it
starts off basically with the navigation
policy right the go to goal so the
behavioral cloning module that we
trained is is in control and it's
driving and it's it's basically you know
trying to mimic all of the other human
demonstrators that did this task you
know which is more or less kind of walk
around and and look for a good spot and
then when the state classifier detects
like okay this is a decent spot that's
when you saw it switch to the all right
let's build the waterfall and then after
we built the waterfall estate class for
our switch to the now go take a picture
subtask
um and so that that that's basically
what you see in this video and one thing
i'll say with this the interesting thing
uh with the navigation policy
is
you know this is something we
kind of noticed and it's just a theory
we don't have any proof on it but like
the
you know and the agent jumps around a
lot um
but we think that's because
um
the agent is mimicking uh the human
demonstrator so like so
jumping for the sake of jumping not
necessarily to jump over stuff like you
know there's there's some players you're
faster if you jump yeah yeah exactly and
and that's seen in the demonstrations or
some players like like me i just jump
idly
you know just a fixation so i'm just
like randomly jumping not not to
particularly jump over anything you kind
of see that in the agent's behavior
so it's almost uh you know
makes it more human-like uh at least in
our opinion versus you know a hard-coded
navigation policy which mainly you know
you might
expect it to just walk without jumping
unless it needs to jump right over
something here you know the agent is
kind of just more
pseudo-randomly jumping like a human
would and we thought that was pretty
cool because you know another part of
this competition that we haven't talked
about yet it's not just you know
developing agents that can do the tasks
the best but also it was a sub uh thread
to the competition of who can build the
most human-like agent uh which we also
uh won that
that
prize uh so you know this would
potentially i mean uh really our whole
system you know
is sort of aims at the human life
because we added a lot of human
knowledge to it but like the behavioral
cloning part you know that might also
add to that because it kind of moves
around
more or less like it like a human would
move around and it it looks a little
less robotic like if it were kind of a
more
hand engineered policy except like here
when when it's like a good spot for a
waterfall you immediately point down and
start like i guess this is the
hard-coded part that you see right now
immediately point down build a bunch of
blocks place the bucket and then it's
it's interesting so this part here is
hard coded as well it's just like move
the agent away and we see the agent kind
of slide on the left
a little bit because i've noticed that
later when it turns around it sort of
almost misses a little bit the angle
um right so this is this could be this
drift that you have in the odometry
estimation so it's trying to
make a picture of the waterfall directly
misses like a little bit so i guess that
would be
that would sort of be the problems that
you get in
just having the um just having the
estimation from the action which you
mentioned yeah so for example when you
throw the the water down right sometimes
the agent will float in the water and
that will turn the agent a little bit
left and right but the odometry doesn't
see that because the asian didn't
command the camera movement so it
doesn't update your heading so that can
also you know cause problems later
but yeah like you said that part was
hardcoded like the the place waterfall
subtask was hard coded but all the way
up to that thing up to that part was
learned from human demonstrations which
is the navigation subtask
what i think what you what you need to
do is you just need to train the
navigation thing on you know dream
you so you you just wanna you just wanna
train it on like a bunch of videos of
dream and then just see what happens i
would be it'd be so curious to see what
happens
well that's we wanted to do that
initially is we thought oh look at all
of this awesome data on youtube that we
could yeah maybe try to learn from but
there's no actions associated with it
yes okay true you'd sort of have to
estimate
the actions almost a little bit and
you'd also have to like there's a lot of
things you'd have to guess at what's
actually going on which where do we crop
the video right there's
all this stuff they have overlaid and it
becomes
more challenging to use uh youtube data
but
i see
okay um
you you
um wait what was i was i gonna
one thing that yeah one thing that
i was a little bit like a tiny bit
dissatisfied with with this competition
obviously it's already super duper
challenging right and minecraft is so
much more complicated than this thing
but there were these four
tasks and you knew them ahead of time
right that's why you were able to sort
of build the state machine
the descriptions were very clear ahead
of time
let's say that i come and i'm the
organizer and i change the challenge for
next year and next year it's still the
same thing it's human rated uh it's
described in just like a simple string
but i won't tell you what the string is
right
i won't tell you ahead ahead of time how
would you how would you go about
uh designing a system like this like
what would you
would you do would you try to go the
same route or let's say you also had
very uh
limited
resources like you had now you can't
train like a giant rl system
well i think
we would definitely
be forced to go a different route which
i think would be good you know one of
the things i like about this competition
again is that it's you know i think it's
important for the field because you know
it's
these tasks again that you can't just
you know do this black box optimization
over because there's no objective
function so you're forced to really try
to learn from a human right or or do
something right um and and and you know
we really took that to heart we knew
like okay in order to do wellness
competition
we cannot just use the human provided
demonstrations like
the majority of the the other teams we
had to add our own
uh additional human
uh input and feedback and and we did
that with the design of our state
machine and in the the labeling the
human exhaustive human labeling that we
added
but
you know to take it a step further
really i think the interesting thing
would be to have a system where you have
you learn from real time human feedback
which our system didn't do
because you know well one is that's more
challenging and we didn't have time and
because all the uh
the tasks are known ahead of time you
don't have to have real-time human
feedback you can you know collect your
human feedback or human labeling
beforehand and then use it but if you
have now a new iteration of this
competition where you do not know the
the tasks ahead of time then you now
might need a system where your agent
needs to learn from human feedback in
real time and kind of interact
with the human to kind of get that
learning
because you know you're just seeing what
you need to do the task
at competition time so i i think that
would be really interesting
and that would force more uh solutions
to to use something that that uses
real-time human feedback
what
set you apart if you
you've probably seen sort of the other
teams that competed and so on and i'm
sure they were also they're also engaged
and motivated and tried a bunch of
things
what do you think was sort of the
or maybe that the most defining factor
that let you win was it i'm sure there
was a level of stochasticity in the
evaluation but you know you won i think
not one but two of the three
subcategories even um so it must mean
that you had
a considerable let's say edge over most
of the competition what in your
estimation was that
i i have a guess you guys can comment on
that
i think in my my opinion i think our
edge was actually using human feedback
data
so like the other teams if i remember
correctly i think number two used the
sort of improved algorithm that would
improve on gail
so that was kind of sort of full rl
approach
the third team tried to use some of kind
of learning from human preference if you
remember that paper but they didn't use
a human to rate the trajectories they
used like a heuristic right and we were
the only team that actually used human
data so
uh we you know we label a bunch of data
you know we added kind of our knowledge
our bias on the task and everything so i
think really using the human i think was
the the key factor that allowed us to
win two or three of the awards
100 like you know yeah we had a state
machine
uh a approach with you know these uh
modular hierarchical design but really
we wouldn't have been able to do that if
we didn't have
you know this classifier that was
generated with additional you know human
feedback and human labeling
um and so it's really the thing that
stood a sound apart like we said it was
you know the other teams they they just
use the human demonstrations and and
even um i think the third place uh
uh team
they used a simulated human right
instead of you know doing the hard work
of actually getting that human female
they just defined us a simple heuristic
and i think that right there is like you
know
the important thing like the field you
know sometimes can just like oh well
let's just it's easier to kind of
simulate out the human let's you know
come up with that better algorithm
but it really just shows like we we
should do a better job trying to
incorporate uh human feedback because
it's definitely you know valuable
information and can really improve
the way we develop our ai algorithms
i think it's important as well that
when you look at at minecraft it's it's
very much feels like an open world
sandbox problem very similar to using a
robot in the real world
and collecting real world data is about
as difficult as i would say
it's a little more challenging in some
ways but
challenging to collect lots of good rich
human demonstrations in this particular
environment and so
if we were looking at this as a
generalized approach to solving this
kind of navigation problem
i think we would have used a similar
approach for handling this on a robot
where
you know robot going to go pick
something up somewhere
can be broken down into a bunch of
discrete steps and we solve each of
those steps really well
whereas an end-to-end approach we
risk having situations where the
neural network is doing something that
we can't debug at all and i think that
hierarchical approach really let us
debug each step really well
as opposed to
the monolithic approach
now just to say in on the on the
leaderboard website there is a team that
has like a better score than you was
that is that an artifact of the one
leader board or is it a late entry after
the competition so that's the that's the
public leaderboard right and it's not
the official reward this is yeah this is
highlights the other difficulty of this
competition is like again there's
nothing to just automatically grade
everything
the you have to just
get volunteers to literally just sit
down and look at uh pairs of videos of
different agents and see which one is
better very very uh arduous task right
and the public leader board is just any
random person with a web browser can go
on and start rating
all the people you know we we've
provided some ratings it's completely
unofficial but it was just used to
kind of determine who would go to the
next round so the the top ten teams and
then the competition organizers actually
hired uh professional contractors you
know um you know but
actually had
you know not just random people but like
contractors
go and do official evaluations to
determine the winners and on that one
uh that's that's where we won first
place but on the public leaderboard
we're we're not showing us first place
because
the stochasticity of all the human
raiders right
i love that the the professional
contractors were probably like they had
to know minecraft right so they're
they're like the most competent people
in it were probably like some 13 year
olds
of kids to watch some videos give some
ratings
excellent
um yeah is there is there anything you
you'd like to that was my exhaustive
list of of questions that i had about
this is there anything you feel is
important to to add for people to know
if they want to do something like this
themselves or
uh
i think i think uh during the
presentation we had the slide about that
so uh so
this competition might happen again next
year or i guess this year already 2022
uh so if you're really interested on
that uh make sure to go ahead and start
playing with the mineral package now
because it took us a long time to to
figure that out i think i think i can
speak for all all three here i think
that was our first time working with the
minecraft package like the reinforcement
learning package so it took us some time
to to learn all the
you know how to work with that their
action space observation space and
everything so if you wanna like an extra
edge this next year you can maybe start
playing with the package now
uh
and i think i think that's it uh maybe
play a lot of minecraft i think that
that helped
uh
yeah
what do you think guys
i mean you mentioned uh like the the
paper that we have but we also have made
our code available for anybody that
wants to try it themselves or improve
upon our solution
awesome i think the paper got the link
to the code
um yeah i'm pretty sure yeah it's there
so yeah go ahead play with our code
maybe make it better let us know maybe
make some pull requests
cool awesome well in this case um thank
you so much for being here and sharing
this it's really i love i like it i
think it's really cool when
when things like this get get out into
the well not real world but minecraft
world which is close enough um it's it's
incredibly hard task and for just from
the videos i saw it i was surprised by
you know just how far
you can get with how little sort of
resources and data
it's just one last thing like the
definitely you know after this first
year's competition the uh
you know this is far from solved and i
think the competition organizers realize
that too so out of the four tasks which
are you know that you already mentioned
you know basically advancing in
difficulty the the fine cave and the
make waterfall the easiest those are
pretty much solved
the create animal pen and especially the
build village
none of those solutions came even close
to really solving that you know i'm sure
the human raiders are just looking at
two really junk agents doing random
stuff and trying to pick which one's
better right but you know it's still
like on that build village task but
still a very simple task out of the
range of tasks that you can conceive in
uh minecraft is still far from from
solving
and i mean yeah there's there's no
crafting yet there is no
fighting there is no exploring and this
isn't even like this this is where
minecraft starts the actual game of
minecraft is where you sort of set your
own goals right and and you try to
achieve something new
yeah it's
it's cool to see that there's still a
lot of a lot of stuff to do
awesome thank you so much for being here
and um yeah i'll i hope to see you next
year again
thank you very much for having us
yannick uh like i said i i watch a bunch
of your videos i really like your
channel i'm excited to see
there it's janik i'm going to leave you
with the submissions of the team to the
competition that were actually judged by
the human annotators so you can see what
the humans saw and what it takes to win
such a competition we'll show you all
the submissions for each of the tasks in
parallel let me know if you liked this
video leave a like if you did and leave
a comment if you have comments
suggestions anything at all see you next
time
[Music]
so
you